we're kicking off our partnership with
Ted to highlight individuals and ideas
that are shaping our world it's all part
of our new series ideas that matter
Huntington West Virginia Fire Chief Jan
Rader is one of those people raters work
fighting the opioid epidemic in her city
is featured in the Emmy winning Netflix
documentary heroine her efforts earned
her a place from this year's time 100
list of the most influential people
Rayder helped establish quick response
teams to visit and speak with patients
within 72 hours of their overdoses she
also helped start proact a one-stop
clinic for those suffering from
substance abuse disorder and she is
focused on self care initiatives for
first responders who help patients in
her TED talk released this morning
Rader says these programs are starting
to make an impact in her community
currently our overdose deaths are down
50 percent this epidemic is far from
over but each and every one of us has a
part to play in this epidemic just by
listening and being kind to somebody you
have the ability to make a D'Oench
difference in their lives
and generator joins us at the table good
morning Happy New Year welcome thank you
for having me thanks for being here
Huntington your city was once called the
overdose capital of America but as you
pointed out you're turning that around
what's working I think that the big
issue or what has really worked as we
have come together as a community we
have hundreds of people working
diligently and taking putting their ego
aside to work on this issue and that
matters you know we have competitors
coming together to form something called
proact to provide a way to get somebody
help within two hours of being assessed
whereas before it might take a couple
days or a week to get somebody help
who's suffering from substance use
disorder
it's an all-hands-on-deck approach right
and the first is taking away the stigma
stigma is huge and it's it's it's huge
in two ways not only for those suffering
from substance use disorder the
for the first responders who are
suffering from compassion fatigue and
need mental health services so we're
trying to work on that helping them is
as important as helping the victim oh
yeah I went to Martin burg a few years
ago and ran into a group of women called
the hope dealers and they they were a
one-stop shop really really were
volunteers out there getting people to
where they needed to go how much are you
pushing efforts like that I you know I
think that it is we're pushing it day
after day after day we've been working
on this in Huntington for four years we
have other communities around the
country coming to talk to us about what
we're doing and what matters
so let's specifically break that down
exactly what you were doing yes first of
all naloxone right the locks own in the
first responders hands and friends and
family we have over 2,000 saves from
friends and family having the locks own
at home
to be able to administer it to their
what took that to happen West Virginia
said here are the resources to do that
or we changed legislative laws so that
we could do that and we got grants so
that we could provide that for our first
responders and our health department was
huge in doing that that has reduced
tests then you talk about self care so
our first responders explain that okay
so this you know first responders we are
the cavalry we want to help somebody in
an instance where you have somebody
suffering from substance use disorder
you might you might narcan them over and
over and over again and then find them
dead and we feel like we can't make a
difference and that takes a toll on us
so we need to provide our first
responders with ways to deal with the
stress that they see and to give them
tools that they can use to help those
suffering like being able to take them
to proact or the quick response team can
actually help them you talk about stigma
and reducing stigma how do you how do
you how do you make that psychological
change in effect both you know both in
among the victims themselves and among
among the public I think that the first
step is talking about it you know we
have to talk about it and it might be a
painful conversation but we have to talk
about it and
and get the information out there what
role does the drug industry play in
terms of flooding your state with
painkillers like these oh they they they
flooded it and you know we can't even in
there's a lot of blame to go around but
the fact of the matter is this is where
we are and we have to move forward and
we don't want to dwell on that we want
to move forward in the past with heroin
and crack there was essentially
criminalization yes of the behavior what
lessons have you learned from that in
terms of the compassion the
compassionate care that you've seen now
somebody suffering from substance use
disorder or addiction is actually
actually a fragile person thank they are
hopeless and the way we treat them can
make their situation better or worse so
even a wisecrack made by somebody can
can make their situation worse so we
need to treat them with kindness and
compassion and and show them that they
are a good person and they that they do
deserve to get better because they can
Jen rade are the first female fire chief
in West Virginia yes you love to see how
your leadership is making real change
they model and inspiration for many
people so nice to have you here chief
thank you and to learn more about
Huntington's compassionate response to
the opioid epidemic and watch Jan's TED
talk congratulations I know that is not
easy
visit our website at CBS this morning
calm
[Music]